Welcome to Module Three — convolutional neural networks, the architecture that made deep learning practical for images.
We'll cover why convolutions beat dense layers, the building blocks, the classic architectures, and transfer learning.
The convolution itself is simple: a small kernel slides across the image, applying the same weights at every position.
That weight sharing is the whole trick — it gives you translation equivariance and a tiny fraction of the parameters a dense layer would need.
The number of filters sets your output channels, and the receptive field grows as you stack layers deeper.
Between convolutions you downsample.
Max pooling keeps the strongest response in a window, average pooling smooths, and a strided convolution does the same thing but learns how.
In modern nets, global average pooling quietly replaces the old dense classifier head.
The architecture story is a quick tour.
LeNet-5 in 'ninety-eight.
AlexNet in twenty-twelve, which added ReLU, GPUs, and dropout to win ImageNet.
VGG went deeper with stacked three-by-three convolutions.
ResNet added skip connections and suddenly a hundred-plus layers trained cleanly.
EfficientNet and ConvNeXt are the modern refinements.
Here's the move you'll use most: transfer learning.
Start from ImageNet weights, freeze the base, and train a small head on your own data.
Then unfreeze and fine-tune with a much smaller learning rate — and match your preprocessing to the pretrained model, keeping batch-norm layers in inference mode at first.
And almost for free, data augmentation regularizes you.
Random flips, crops, and rotations are built into Keras; MixUp, CutMix, and RandAugment go further.
Just apply it during training only, and lean on it harder when your dataset is small.
Let's build and visualize a CNN — open the labs.